when the moon hits your eye like a big
pizza pie it's Andrew Cuomo and you're
listening to this fool like pasta fazool
is Chris Cuomo and the garlic knot tells
you you gotta stay inside and you listen
did you see the video with Chris Cuomo
it's on yet a beat coronavirus by
breathing cuz Chris Cuomo had
coronavirus and he's like a guy called
me cuz yo Chris gone was a tough guy
ain't gonna let the virus beat me I'm a
[ __ ] garlic knot so Chris Cuomo sees
like a pulmonologist called me and told
me he's like Chris you got that Corona
you gotta do it you gotta got up the
virus wants you in your bed these guys a
tough guy couldn't handle the word
frayed out the virus wants you in your
bed you got to get up and breathe deep
it's literally can we play that yeah
Chris Cuomo giving people advice and at
a beat coronavirus by doing some weird
chest yoga which may help I don't know
but I mean I mean maybe he's right maybe
the pulmonologist is right I just have a
low opinion of the Cuomo family he's
like you gotta breathe you gotta get the
virus once you are here we go this is it
okay so here's what I've learned here's
the secret to kicking this virus just a
secret potion
it's about your a will he said bye you
will devotion if the vibration wants us
to lay down the virus water lay down are
you a fan oke other than the Blessed few
the rest of us who get this are gonna
have an experience unlike anything else
they've ever had days and waves the old
notion of getting bed and stay there
when you get sick it sounds great and if
you're really up against it you need to
do as little as possible I love that
this is all written why can't anyone
like I do it all the time why can't you
just talk like why can't he speak like
he's reading something that's written
clearly right why can't he just sit talk
cuz every speech is just prepared for
him in public right I mean does he even
have corona VII or we are these people
lying that like these celebrities to say
they have it if they really have it some
of these people on their instagrams are
like you know man
it's been very hard for me did you like
this little cloth track like is this
real did your agent call you and go hey
ah you got it you gotta you gotta come
out that you got co fat 19 there are
agents calling people right now god
here's the best move for you right now
COFF COFF a lot on instagram live
because you need people need to follow
your kovat 19 journey so listen I'm
gonna play some of this because maybe
Chris Cuomo is right okay what you know
Bob Grant who is a phenomenal
conservative radio huh there's gonna be
a conservative show everybody we did a
we did a communist show last week we're
gonna oscillate we go fascist communist
every other week keep everybody happy
okay I don't know who's gonna win but
what I will whatever boot is on your
neck as to what I support so a Bob grant
whatever you think of his politics
you're racist whatever but a great you
know radio guy old-time radio die you go
get off my phone and people would call
him up they built Bob it's Pony from
Seaside Heights
it was always Tony from Seaside Heights
a long time list the first time caller
Bob what do you think about and they
they were just some [ __ ] he'd go you
know what Tony he do me a favor
you fake phony fraud that was just
kissed agony god that was his you know
signature line he'd go you fake phony
fraud get off my phone and he kick him
off the phone he used to call the
Cuomo's father Mario Cuomo I think he
called them son of swatching now I don't
know what that means it's probably bad
but Bob Grant used to be a sign of
swatching all right P Bob Grant Bob
Grant got kicked off WABC radio because
when Ron Brown a Clinton associate was
killed in a plane crash that's a shock
someone near the Clintons killed Bob
Grant said something like the only good
news
coming out of this would be if we find
that Ron Brown his dad and he did die
and Bob Grant was kicked off he was
kicked off ABC and then he went to wor
and I used to make my grandmother listen
to Bob Grant while she would drive me
like to and from play practice and dance
class so that's how gay Republicans come
to be you go to dance class and you
listen to Bob Grant and Rush Limbaugh on
the way all gay people by the way
secretly Republican that's true all of
them every single one of them I'm dead
I'm joking about that somebody by the
way you want to talk about rotted brains
someone on instagram accused me this is
great they go in your latest sketch you
say thee of a wife and I'm like the
sketch is me playing a owner of a like a
developer who owns properties and I'm
evicting people and he goes with don't
you think that saying a wife instead of
husband is like a little [ __ ] up and
I'm like the point of the sketch is that
I'm a demon from hell
real estate developer evicting nurses
from the building and and kicking people
to the street and this is how identity
politics rots people's heads he's like
yeah but you said so I'm like so your
problem is that the demon real estate
developer isn't get you want him to be
gay in the sketch that's on Instagram
that's what you want let's let's
continue here with Chris Cuomo who does
not have coronavirus I know but you
can't stay there now I'm wise to the
beast and it sways it changes
the fever is just softened by the way he
means by the way he beast his ways he
means Jews that's what he means by that
and then they had to you know what him
and his brother say behind closed doors
you know they're small-minded sauce
monkeys you know they are you know what
they say when they get a [ __ ] ball of
sauce on the table and they take a
couple of hunks of bread and dip it into
the pot of sauce you know they got a
couple of
words for who owns the media that again
I'm imagining that's what they do I have
no proof of that that's something I'm
imagining Chris and his Neanderthal
brother do cuz they're Neanderthals you
look at Andrew Cuomo's face he's a
Neanderthal he's in the end Rafal andrew
Cuomo Chris Cuomo is a little you know
whatever can your body hurts so you
don't want to move your body because
what it wants to do is get in your lungs
that's what it wants to do I feel it
constricting my chest when I had that
chest x-ray did I I saw that infiltrate
right away
now I also have something else I haven't
told you I have a low IgM level I would
want the primary I have something else
and it was of a low IQ in fact it was
embarrassing for my family to find out
how low it was I'm basically
functionally [ __ ] that's why I have
to read a script right now instead of
just talking to you like a normal person
about my experiences with coronavirus I
have to read a prepared statement
because I'm genuinely on the border of
mental retardation and I have a
television show I genuinely have a
television show and cannot process
information like other people so I have
to have a prepared statement about my
sickness bonza antibody I've always had
a low level okay it's not something
recent it could be genetic it could be
cultural I don't know but it makes me
susceptible to things like bronchitis
and crap like that so there I was on
Friday night okay I was not gonna do the
show tonight I was done I was in a pool
of sweat 12 hours later I was in the
same damn place I hadn't slept a minute
I was just soaked and scared honest to
god so then I get a call from a friend
of a friend of a friend
now this keeps happening to me now this
new reality of how much people just care
I have this new network of not just
sources but really good people and they
all come this way a friend of a friend
of a friend do you think your brothers
do you think Chris let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question here
do you think some of that network is cuz
your brother's to governor
do you think that's a possibility I
don't know do you think that I'm not
sure do you think it's cuz you have a
television show some people you said got
this great Network now if people that
truly care about me do you really care
keep going battling this all over the
country in the world and people want to
beat the beast so this doctor calls me
up asked me about my symptoms he's a
pulmonary expert and says can you get up
I say yeah I can get up he says do it he
says can you stretch your torso I said
what do you how great was somebody
pranking Chris Cuomo like somebody just
getting them to do like how are you yes
this is Daniel Cohen I'm a pulmonary
expert at Langone I'm just calling you
can you get up right now can you stretch
your torso can you do you know the funky
chicken dance I want you to do that
right now and I know you're gonna laugh
but I'm gonna tell you right now the
funky chickens movements open up the
passageways in your lungs that get the
virus out so I want you to do that right
now and I want you to do it outside of
your house
because it's you need the fresh air can
you do the running man can you do the
running man right now can you let me
tell you why the running man increases
circulation in such a way that the virus
is less able to bind to your red blood
cells can you do the running man right
now
can you put you a video of you doing the
running man on your Instagram account
right now can you do that let me ask you
another question and this is gonna seem
but you guys stick with me I'm the head
pulmonologist can you do blackface can
you do let me tell you why blackface
helps if you put blackface on your face
the virus gets scared because the virus
is racist you know the way Asians feel
about blacks the virus is very racist so
if you do blackface the virus doesn't
get in there do you see what I mean you
want to keep going yeah we gotta like
this oh yeah no it doesn't feel that
good he said do it he said can you [ __ ]
I said probably not do it you [ __ ] do
it do it
and then who is this
can load she said he heard me so we
wanted to keep this out of my lungs and
he said it's in your lungs and you got
the right fear and you got the wrong
approach
you can't wait it out he said you have
to fight I'm not in some silly
metaphorical way
this isn't about like channeling rocky
or eye of the tiger you've got to do the
things that will beat this virus you've
got to breathe deep when it hurts and it
hurts I know it hurts and I'm not trying
to minimize anybody's pain when you get
a fever spiked and that hurts he said
you can't take confidence that it's
gonna go down they're gonna be spikes
for at least 10 days when you get a
fever you got a layer up you got a drink
you got it's amazing about this virus by
the way no and we're done with him but
nobody has any clue at all what's going
on like nobody has any like not a clue
right no but fever for 10 day like what
are we saying here what are we talking
about what is going on nobody has a clue
now they said you read something says
soap doesn't do anything ventilators
make it worse doesn't kill the
coronavirus yeah yeah ventilators make
it worse soon they're gonna say hand
sanitizer spreads it like whoa what do
you know hand sanitizer
you like this too now it's saying 13
feet well these are scare monger
articles these coronavirus found in air
samples up to 13 feet away another thing
they don't know if it's infectious
particles or not like you know listen
man
they found corona virus on that cruise
ship the diamond princess the Grand
Princess whatever-it-was did that what
was it called diamond princess I want to
go on a cruise to the diamond princess I
want to go how you're gonna love it
it's the Diamond Princess cruise I want
it to go somewhere in Mexico but nowhere
scary the diamond princess only
seventeen percent of people on the boat
contracted the virus which means and
listen to me because I am a
microbiologist okay I you know I have a
doctorate and by
uncle engineering I've worked you know
people know what I am that material on
the on this it's the RNA of the virus
the RNA the ribonucleic acid that the
RNA of the virus not the infectious
material so it's not infectious after 17
days they don't know if the particles in
the air 13 feet away from you are
infectious or not they just don't know
no one knows they keep saying fast food
and [ __ ] safe so I went to Taco Bell the
other day and I'm even on the drives
from like this ain't safe there's no way
this is okay they just want poor people
to die
everything poor people do is safe by the
way they let get drive-throughs is safe
yeah sucking a guy off on a bus is safe
yeah there's no risk and sucking a guy
off on a bus listen if that's how you
make your money and we can send less of
a stimulus out that's safe yeah hooking
is safe yes selling your [ __ ] on the
street is absolutely safe for Kovan 19
don't worry about it
ya know sell an illegal weapon it
doesn't on guns is fine it doesn't live
on guns I've at it doesn't live on guns
have at it animals have at it we took
sports away the least we can give you is
a little gunplay in the street to make
up for it you need to do something
special they really are letting the poor
die they just don't give a [ __ ] and what
I I'm like amazed you're like they can't
say that postmates cuz by the way posts
mates is it's all the same risk we had
[ __ ] delivery tonight they're gonna
be korone on a napkin nobody knows it's
all the same risk you leave your house
it's a risk just everything's a risk I'm
getting an antibody test to see if I had
it I want to know if I had it and if it
if it if I did not have it I will throw
a fit this is what we're all gonna do
because by the way no one had it
everyone's full of [ __ ] I love these
things people like I was he was anyone
else sick in December it was the sickest
I'd ever been into
so it was late December early January
and I was sick was anyone else sick like
that man
yes I was sick I was too your people get
sick you [ __ ] morons it's not kovat
19 no now I was sick in early March and
I was from coming back from Vancouver
and there was there are many Asians a
lovely proud people but many of them
lived in Vancouver I'm just saying
that's what it is so I'm thinking that
perhaps I got the virus in Vancouver and
I brought it back here and I think I had
it in early March I was diagnosed which
trap but then I had a call for three
weeks I had a fever I it was bad I was
sweating I was said some little chills
and whatever it was not good so I think
I had kovat 19 I think I had Corona no I
don't know if I did and and what's gonna
happen is we're all gonna take these
antibody tests and they're gonna show
that none of us had the corona virus and
we're all gonna flip out and say those
tests aren't real and they're not
effective and that the person who gave
it to us can [ __ ] off cuz we know we had
it they're idiots out there they're like
I know I had it I know for a fact I had
it I had every symptom of it then they
started listening these symptoms are not
at all karana virus my stomach hurt I
stubbed my toe it's like no that's not
it you goon guys the Tim Dylan show is
always looking to make you comfortable
stylish and safe here's a reality right
now it is so important to be able to
have something that you carry on you
that you can sanitize easily and that is
a ridge wallet Ridge wallet is the best
why what is it Ben it's what's the thing
it's metal right yeah it's a minimal
front pocket wallet that's designed to
streamline what you carry every day
what's kind of metal is it titanium yeah
that's a carbon fiber and titanium so it
comes in titanium them right carbon
fiber aluminum titanium easily dude you
put a little hand sanitizer on your hand
you sanitize the ridge and super easy
you got a big leather wallet you can't
really do that it becomes a problem you
know easily sanitize surfaces is the
move right now okay especially with the
outbreak of corona virus okay Ridge well
it's great we all use them I have it Ben
has it ten percent off today Ridge comm
slash t IM ridge comm slash t IM use the
code t IM link in description i'll tell
you this man that's i mean other than
the fact that it's a great wallet it
streamlines everything you don't want
these big wallets it's easier you carry
some cash and cards boom it forces you
to be organized it forces you to
eliminate the [ __ ] you don't need in
your life you know i mean i think a
perfect rich wallet is 100 dollar bill
to do cocaine with your lawyers card
your your credit card debit card
whatever and a picture of somebody you
know where you're really gonna do some
bad you look at them again
I shouldn't that's a perfect Ridge set
you don't really need much more than
that but also right now man it's so easy
to sanitize that becomes so important
you take a lie Sol wipe to the ridge
you're good there's too many creeks and
crevices in a big leather wallet and
people are going to be killed by having
them cuz Corona is gonna jump out of one
of the compartments and [ __ ] you in your
face is that what you want you want
Corona to [ __ ] your nose hole now so I
would get Ridge I have Ridge but if I
didn't have Ridge I ded Ridge I kill my
family to earn the money to get Ridge
I'll tell you that much if I had to I
don't give a [ __ ] I'd call from my
grandma it came down to what I get -
goddamn Ridge though it's got thirty
thousand five star reviews it's a better
way to carry your cash and cards I cut
my best friend's throat a fate if I
could get a Ridge wallet swear to god
there's no oath I wouldn't break I'd
sell this country out for a rich wallet
I'd walk right into China with all our
nuclear secrets [ __ ] and Shanghai with a
ridge wallet and watch them black
[ __ ] out of us everybody I know and
everything I know go up in a mushroom
cloud I'm just sitting there with a
ridge wallet I don't give a [ __ ]
not even more than one just one I
wouldn't even need more than one you
just need one there's nothing I really
wouldn't do for a Ridge wallet Ridge
well it mmm
Red Robin mmm
those gonna be the only restaurants that
survive AG Red Robin yeah all the good
ones you're gonna go away but the people
that need to read Robin don't give a
[ __ ] they'll go right in there they'll
go right in there in a hospital gown
discharged from the hospital that walk
right into Red Robin and I give a [ __ ]
Red Robin mmm Ridge wallet mmm do it
folks Ridge wallet is gonna be very
important in the fight against AIDS and
coronavirus easy sanitize I'd get AIDS
if I could get a Ridge wallet not even
HIV full-blown AIDS inject me with a
needle of full-blown AIDS right into my
eyeball just give me a Ridge you could
blind me I could be deaf dumb and blind
I just want to feel that Ridge feel that
cool titanium in my hand would you kill
your fiancee for Ridge I mean I already
have one you mean like if I didn't have
one if you didn't have one you know what
I'm saying would you strangle your
fiancee for a ridge I mean know what let
me ask you why not because it's just a
wallet like it's a [ __ ] this is why
Ben is not really successful in life he
can't commit to anything cuz he's a
[ __ ] okay he's a [ __ ] she doesn't
listen to this [ __ ] show by the way
she doesn't [ __ ] listen to the show
she's listening to Tom Segura who'd pays
you zero money so she should keep
listening to that network you've earned
not a dollar from anyway Ridge calm
slash Jim Hughes code P I am buy the
[ __ ] wallet okay enough already I got
from a friend
got to hand sanitizer it's a lavender
hand sanitizer with a very high alcohol
content and when I spread it all over my
hands I breathe it in deep because it
smells like gin and I used to love
Beefeater gin I spent years in a pool of
lukewarm Beefeater gin Beefeater in and
out
martini meaning you put the vermouth in
the glass and by the way if you are a
drinker out there please enjoy this
cocktail and and and I'll tell you
exactly how to do it I don't usually
give cocktail recommendations on the
program because I am a degenerate
alcoholic so many people are disturbed
when I do that but take some vermouth
extra dry vermouth you swirl it around
the glass you throw it out in and out in
and out the martini go right out there
then you put then you take the gin you
stir the [ __ ] gin you don't shake it
like you're a 24 year old [ __ ]
bartender in West Hollywood whose
[ __ ] shake in the gin and trying to
see how many [ __ ] she can fit in her so
she can pay a rent that ain't it okay
you're not gonna you're not shaking a
[ __ ] thing and bruising the goddamn
gin waiting for your [ __ ] seeking
arrangement state to pick you up and
take you to his [ __ ] house
enough you're stirring the gin you stir
it
shaking it bruises it it splits in lines
from James Bond it's absolutely true and
let me tell you right now I threw my
life away for this trick I mean I threw
my life away for this drink this Studios
in an apartment in a Hollywood I am more
talented than 90% of people that live in
this city and they all live in castles
so the reality is I am [ __ ] and it was
because of this cocktail I've not had a
meaningful relationship in my life
because it is cocktail I have very few
friends the ones I have that I've had
for a very long time I'd strongly
dislike I I have no honesty with myself
or others I am a shell of a human being
genuine shell of a human being I live to
entertain people to make them happy for
nothing for no reason I barely enjoy
that it's just
what I have to do I'm built to do
nothing else I'm just a vector of
negative energy that will either go into
a heroin needle or go into a stupid joke
I tell it [ __ ] you know the [ __ ]
you know the giggle [ __ ] the giggle
Pig which should be the name of a comedy
club in is it
welcome to the giggle Pig don't take out
your phones this is art but what I'm
saying is all of that happen I should
have been I should have came out of the
closet earlier I should have did the
right thing I shouldn't went to college
I didn't do any of that
I was his subprime mortgages I was dumb
enough to sell the product to myself I
sold the house to myself you're not
supposed to get so drunk you scammed
yourself i scammed myself the Enron
idiots weren't buying their own bed [ __ ]
like you know so I did it all for this
perfect drink it is a perfect trick and
I'm glad I was an alcoholic when I look
back on the world I'm glad it wasn't you
know family friends accomplishments I
know a lot of people with those and I
got to be honest with you truly it's
truly or whatever
your kids are [ __ ] half the time they
take advantage of you they don't value
the sacrifices you made for them your
wife or husband doesn't really care and
and and your career you hit a wall with
that and no one really gives a [ __ ]
truly no one cares I just watched a
documentary about a bunch of comedians
that came out of New York City in the
alt scene and everything and some of
them are funny and some of them aren't
but the point is truly no one kidding no
one cares no one cares you care about
david dobrik and they're not gonna care
about him soon they won't care about him
soon they'll care about something that
just makes sounds and Biebs they'll go
give the better educator your kids like
the most will be somebody that goes so
it's over and nothing matters so you
take the vermouth and you swirl it
around in the glass you spill it out and
then you put the gin which should be and
this is another great line which isn't
mine I don't know who wrote this vodka
goes down too easy gin drinkers like to
know what you're up against that's why I
didn't like Bombay Sapphire it's too
smooth I like Beefeater I like a little
punch I
like a little punch in the back of the
throat of juniper berry and botanical
and lavender I like to feel where I'm
going cuz this listen martinis gin
martinis take you to the moon martinis
are like breasts
one is not enough two is alright three
is too many
four is a party I didn't do that either
that's something else I don't know a guy
told me that name Huey he's dead the
point is this he had a lot of great
he said one other thing that I left so
hard it wasn't his but he remembered it
he goes
she brought he said this at dinner he
goes she broke my heart so I broke her
jaw again I don't know where you got it
it's probably the famous thing it's very
funny anyway he was I saying you're just
describing yeah so the dress takes you
to the moon it takes you to the moon you
get [ __ ] up when you get banged up on
martinis you get bang the [ __ ] up you do
not I mean it's a bad it's a boom like
you are it's no word like you're at work
to next day with a pounding headache
it's a real hangover you got to do a
couple of percocet in the morning or a
couple of vicodin with that with that
[ __ ] Starbucks latte and that Newport
or marlboro menthol light or Marlboro
light or Marlboro red or Parliament you
get the idea or vape the point is and
I've smoked all those cigarettes that's
why I went through them the point is I
used to smoke basic unfiltered yeah back
when I was a kid I was 13 years old in
my friend Shay got a pack a basic
unfiltered we got a pack one they have
Benson & Hedges we used to just buy
different types of cigarettes L&M
Liggett & Myers what a good documentary
about cigarettes not about how [ __ ] up
they are about the tradition of tobacco
which did probably have to do that's
probably that's gets into slaves
but not that I mean a recent like what
were all the cigarette companies and I'm
interested in I want to know about that
I'm gonna die one day because of them I
want to know more about them not just a
rat documentary like rat Leah Remini
everybody hates Scientology now that
they're millionaires but they didn't
they didn't hate it they didn't mind
torturing the kids when it was getting
them all the opportunities I see you
rats you're all full of [ __ ] okay you
don't do something for thirty [ __ ]
years and then decide it's not for you
shut the [ __ ] up go out like the [ __ ]
mafia and suck David Miscavige's dick
alright anyway the drink this is my
point here I keep getting back I keep it
away from this but the drink but the
vermouth then put to gin no olives
olives are for women my boss told me
that my boss was uh guy named Tim that I
worked for him mortgages had a scar
across his face he said I said how did
you get that because I was thrown out of
a car at four years old through the
windshield I said that's crazy he goes
yeah he goes it taught me about
responsibility no one knew what that
meant
no one asked him but he said Allah's are
for women it's a great point if you of a
blue cheese stuff olive in your mouth
you're a woman that's it or you're gay I
guess we could say that but even gay
guys predominantly are probably I don't
know I don't know that the martini
people martinis are for you know
martinis are for people that want to go
to the moon they don't have to want to
go to the moon with a drink or two they
don't have time to sit there for the
whole they need to be [ __ ] up by the
appetizer I needed to be in the bag by
the appetizer if bruschetta or tuna
tartare hit the table and I wasn't in a
bag we had a problem I needed to have
that gin glow on my face that heat that
heat on my face before the appetizer hit
the table so it's very important that
you make to drink the right way just
just lukewarm gin in a martini glass
you can even I didn't have removed
sometimes I just do it with the gin it's
nice if you have a martini shaker you
could do it in a milk glass you know big
bar glass water glass you can do that
little stir you know it's it's here's
the thing folks and a lot of people
won't tell you this it's it is classy to
throw your life away drinking
certain drinks martinis kettle on the
rocks whiskey bourbon scotch
they're nice something nice about
throwing your life away like that not
beer
that's low-rent but like a liquor
alcoholic I always said good for him
that's somebody that knows where they're
going and that really wants to get there
as quickly as possible when you were
boozing it up you drank beer right light
beer that's light be I mean you can't
can even be proud of that but you didn't
even have a good with it what did you
drink from college to what you were till
to what like 19 to like 25 yeah yeah I
would say that was me too I think I was
like 19 and 25 because I was drugs from
13 to 20 and of course from 20 to 25 as
well but I I got into booze when I was
done with all the other drugs when I
quit everything else I moved into booze
I graduated to booze the good old kettle
one on the rocks with a black fly in the
glass from the good old bartenders at
Lisa's lounge but that's that's what I
mean you know I threw my entire life
away for that drink and I don't regret
it either I don't it was a great there's
nothing better than a Sunday afternoon
getting shit-faced yeah and going to
sleep in your car yeah you know you know
getting really sure there was a place
called Churchill's and Rockville Center
and I was asked to leave twice because I
think one of the women in Churchill's
one of the women I was I was drunk and
it was 11 a.m. and I was telling my
table of people how important it was
that we continue to support the people
of Iraq by sending more troops and money
I was screaming and top my lungs and
yelling and a woman started screaming at
me from across - you don't know what
you're talking about I and I was
screaming and I was drunk I think I
called her a terrorist and I was asked
to leave
I was really rare and ago I believed in
the Bush administration
and then I and then I stopped doing
cocaine and drinking and then I was like
wow it's amazing what happens when you
start looking at things through the lens
of somebody that's you know not doing
cocaine and drinking daily you do get a
better idea of what's going on in the
world I mean I used to go nuts like I
used to get coked out of my face
put a bunch of friends in my suburban
drive around and really wealthy areas in
Long Island and point to the houses and
go they deserve this money
hey desire yeah better than we are
screaming sweating screaming and my
friends like yeah yeah back of the car
they were terrified they're like are we
gonna die what's wrong with this guy
I mean they deserve it don't take their
money make your own money and then
sometimes the car would run out of gas
like in the middle of those cuz I hadn't
put gas in it I would just stand outside
of the car screaming just smoking
cigarettes and screaming like what I say
I completely destroyed my life I mean
you know it's I'm sure you know there's
elements of it that are fun but you know
I should have just vlogged that's what I
should have done I should have logged
everything I liked about the world is
live other than this podcast everything
I like you stand up and you know what
that music theater all that [ __ ] so
alive it's in a stage it's real things
can go wrong
you know floggings edited and that's the
generation we live and we live we live
now in the time of editing and every all
and everything you put out there for the
most part a lot of these guys and some
of them are really talented at the way
they do this and editing is certainly a
talents skill some would say it's an art
form they'd be you know whatever but
that's what we are we're living in an
edited we're living in a time of editing
and everybody's adding it and what I
always was drawn to was live unedited
[ __ ] it was raw and it was right in
front of you and if it [ __ ] sucked it
sucked and if it was great it was great
and if it was
somewhere in the middle which it usually
was it was somewhere in the middle and
maybe it had moments of brilliance it
maybe didn't and maybe it tipped at the
end and you were bored but it wasn't
ever you couldn't duplicate it you
couldn't play it back you couldn't show
your friend unless they were standing
next to you there was something cool
about that that's why I've always liked
restaurants and it's why I like comedy
shows I like things you that even though
there's a level of consistency it's one
and done like it's just - yeah we had a
great dinner and then we went back to
her nights and it we sucked and then you
like what was it even good you see comic
destroy then you see him the next time
with the same jokes and it doesn't work
you're like wait a minute that magic was
gone was it the audience was it him was
it her what was it you know see that's
what we're moving away from we're moving
into this world where everything is
edited and everybody's going to be able
to release the parts of themselves you
know that they think are the best and
it's just it's gonna suck I'm a little
depressed about you know how tough it's
gonna be for live performance let's read
let's read an ad here we're gonna read
it in real time the Tim Dylan show is
brought to you by the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation Bill and Melinda Gates
we stick a needle in the third world and
see what happens
that many of you are angry that Bill and
Melinda have sponsored the show you've
accused me of shilling for them they did
buy ads they did commit to ads you know
Bill and Melinda Gates are going all
over the third-world sticking needles
and children and seeing how they react
and that's heroic
I think it's heroic they are weird
aren't they those two they are a little
off I'm not an anti-vaxxer I think we
need vaccinations but you know the
reality is I don't research these
companies that make vaccinations and I
don't know what Bill and Melinda are up
to I'm always very suspicious when they
go well we're billionaires but now we
want to save the world and it's like
okay and listen maybe they are I don't
know I don't know anything about I
really I don't know much about them you
know I know they're doing some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in the third
world like the things they're doing and
I guess their attitude is well these
kids are gonna die anyway so I don't
know but they're I'm very skilled listed
them everybody the way the people
looking at conspiracies now the problem
is everybody's like they're trying to
surveil me and everything it's like
they're let's set folks you I don't want
to I don't want to I want to break this
to you and in a way that's you've got
nothing left you know like you you don't
have anything left here
nobody's serve it like everybody's like
the new thing is like tick tock like
David hog is like we got a band tick
tock
cuz it's a Chinese national security
weapon because the Chinese they have all
that access to you know all these kids
have access to everything they have got
all that data of the kid what trying to
invest in all of that in tick tock to
prove what our kids are retards you tell
me we couldn't email China and said that
yeah our kids are sociopaths that dance
around doesn't matter what's happening
we could light the world on fire they
literally dance I mean that's the big
what is this surveillance where you know
listen I'm not saying you should have
been concerned about surveillance years
and years and years and years ago this
isn't new remember how none of you gave
a [ __ ] because Osama bin Laden was gonna
come down the chimney and cut all your
throats and now everybody's concerned
about surveillance have been surveilling
had been reading to do it every day
you didn't care to a [ __ ] month ago
you shouldn't care so it's again which
Monday morning quarterbacking the whole
thing then you're not gonna win the
government in this country if you ever
pose a serious threat to them they're
going to vaporize you in some matter
your car goes into a tree they leak a
bunch of info anja they find they audit
your but they will they will break your
spirit or they'll break your head that's
just what happens if you get to be a big
enough threat this is not to defend any
of the new surveillance measures this is
not to say you shouldn't be vigilant
this is not to say you shouldn't pay
attention to what's going on but this is
to make you honestly understand that
everybody in this country acts like they
woke up and learned
everything today everybody acts like it
just dawned on them that things are
[ __ ] this minute where have you been
where were you where were you when this
was going on through Obama before Obama
during Bush where were you then I just
don't understand I understand you know
there's nothing to take here they don't
care about your lives as much as you
think they do they just want you to work
and earn money and they don't want you
to have health insurance and they don't
want you to be able to have the money to
challenge them in and they don't want
you to have the type of democratic
representation that you should have
that's why they [ __ ] gerrymander and
[ __ ] up the districts all the goddamn
time they'd rather you not vote they
don't want you to do anything this is
and this is all a problem by the way I'm
not saying none of it's a problem but
like this idea that like they're spying
on me it's like yeah it's a it's a it's
an issue and they're spying on you
because they want to sell you more crap
for the most part they want to sell your
data to people so they could sell you
more [ __ ] so they can find that the best
way to market a pizza right down your
throat if they could drone pizzas down
your throat that's what a lot of it is
and yes if you start kicking up dust and
and challenging the status quo which
none of you do anyway but if you were to
do that like mr. michael hastings then
you meet the tree you meet mr. tree so
that's what it is I'm not trying to be
black pilling I don't want to be
dispirit in here but these this this pad
everyone's at level 12 panic about
everything but nobody cared you know
they're gonna vaccinate us all yeah
probably gonna be a vaccination for this
we probably need it they're gonna put
chips in us that's a problem I don't I
don't want any of that I don't want any
of that that's that's a bad road to go
down but again it's you know they might
not think I might not put a chip in yeah
they might take off
they don't need to they don't need to
put a chip in you to control you they're
already kind of controlling you all the
things that you think you're not going
to be allowed to do you'll probably be
allowed to do them you're gonna be
allowed to go out to the buffalo heart
and order the fire you know you're gonna
be able to go out and go to the Fried
Chicken and grenade stand that you like
you're gonna be able to do that but it's
you if you again if you try to like
unionize you try to get some [ __ ]
money yourself respect or try to say hey
I don't want to come in today I've got
Corona they're gonna say [ __ ] you get in
here and die on the factory floor that
they're gonna do so be a little more
concerned about nobody's concerned about
any of that by the way
nobody cares about any of that it's all
about Satan and it's an ancient
religious war and no it's not when you
really figure out what it is
it's the ultimate black pill cuz it's
not Satan and [ __ ] what you people
think it's trade routes when you figure
out the whole thing
the blackmail the nightmares the murder
it's all to protect ports and trade
routes and ways to get oil to the
Caspian Sea and ways to protect
interests of very wealthy people it's
the ultimate black well you like you're
doing all this so that billionaires can
be trillionaires
that's it it's not because it's some
blood oath some ancient religion please
tell me it's at least that please wait a
minute you're not even lizard you're not
a let you we're the same species and you
treat me like this
it's even worse I wish they were lizards
it would make you feel better you'd at
least get to go to bed and go oh they're
lizards though they're the same species
and they still don't give a [ __ ]
they've got the same blood in their
veins or not [ __ ] you know when I say
their lives is from another planet to
joke it's scarier that they're from this
planet and they don't give a [ __ ] about
you and all the [ __ ] they do the
skullenbones are [ __ ] all the all the
weird stuff yes they're morbid [ __ ]
people yes they're a cult
yes blah blah blah but what drives it
what drives the secret groups and what
drives to seek
see and the bonding and the blackmail is
money it's the ability to earn money and
to have nobody get in the way of them
earning money ah listen so when the
conspiracy talk gets going I'm I'm with
you I just don't want to hear about time
machines I don't want to hear about
queuing aah I don't want to hear about
Donald Trump you give it a time machine
I don't wanna hear JFK jr. still alive
tell me something normal tell me the
government blew up the Federal Building
in Oklahoma that's something I'll
discuss over brunch when we're allowed
to have it
tell me about 9/11 talk to me about you
know the Boston Marathon bombing and by
the way Raycom prod up a great point
today he said no shootings none of these
kids are shooting anybody with Kovac 19
you want you start to wonder if some of
these school shootings are not as random
as they appear because nobody's gone
into a farmers market with a gun and
don't go do that now that I've said it
but the point is that when you start
thinking about it and I'm not saying the
school shootings are fake or staged what
I'm saying is that it is interesting
it's it's very there hasn't been any
random acts of violence since this you
know there hasn't been any of that
that's kind of gone you know they
canceled that too I got right we're like
day 31 and just nothing nothing
interesting maybe these random acts of
violence we all experience aren't so
random I told you it's gonna be
conservative show today I told you that
early on and that might matter today was
not the episode for you but what I'm
saying is that I know there's a call to
people out there I'm not saying you're
aren't trust me I'm well aware of it I
know more about it than you I've had
more people I've had real conversations
if you join the patreon that you took to
Nick Bryant he'll [ __ ] scare the [ __ ]
out of you and he scared the [ __ ] out of
me with that episode and it was [ __ ]
wild read about the finders read about
the [ __ ] they're into know the FBI said
that actually the finders warrant up
will you shut up the FBI said if you
ever start a sense with the FBI said and
it's not a complete joke I have no
respect
for you well the FBI people are
murderers the FBI so yeah go read about
that stuff but then just don't [ __ ]
come out the other way telling me that
you know Tom Hanks is running a global
and I don't know anything about him he
seems sweet but a lot of people so did
Harvey Weinstein he seemed like a big
teddy bear cuz he is now I I don't know
these people you can't say what they're
into what they're not into her I don't
go to these parties I don't know these
people it is what it is you know living
with chronic pain is the worst it's more
than a feeling of discomfort it can
affect your whole life many of my
listeners probably have some type of
pain that has prevented them from
relaxing and sleeping any much of it is
internal isn't it guys but some of it is
external
maybe you can't exercise because you
pain podcast host to provide experience
of recent pain I do get lower back pain
enter Oh max health if you're looking at
rid of nagging muscle and joint pain
immediately while providing long lasting
recovery then you need to try the
natural breakthrough pain relief
solution cryofreeze CBD roll-on
developed by Omak south and i have tried
this and i do like it
it's non-prescription it's a triple
action pain relief roll-on and it's
specially formulated to block pain
receptors reduce inflammation and prove
muscle and joint flexibility so 100%
natural CBD powered remedy works its
magic within ten minutes of application
and it lasts about eight hours it's a
better version of a like a salonpas or a
what's the what's the other thing what's
the other thing you put on your back
like it's a you know like a icy freeze
or i see how icy hi yeah or salonpas
like that a little bit this is a better
version of it I think because I've used
this other ones too you know and listen
they're gonna give you 20% off if you
have this you want to try it out if you
enjoy the show it's a great way to
support the show and relieve some pain
cryofreeze CBD pain relief roll-on plus
free shipping this discount also applies
towards any products i
why just go - Oh max health.com today
and enter code Tim OMA X HEA LTH calm
today an entry code Tim that's Oh max
health.com
enter code Tim to get 20% off cryofreeze
and site-wide so you've got other things
as well still not sold I could tell you
pro athletes such as PGA pro golfer kyle
Stanley uses cryofreeze CBD to recover
both on and off the course go look at
the product review is 95% five-star
review it's not a [ __ ] product this
is actually good and it works if you
have the pain if you have a problem
lower back joint pain muscles things
like that this is an easy fix it's an
easy fix you know if you're like me
you're an ex-addict and you don't want
to take CBD another way this is a great
way to just put it on the part of you
that hurts and it works its magic it's
an anti-inflammatory it really works
[ __ ] ten times better than a leave
and [ __ ] like that and those are not
good anyway because this is all-natural
one of the reasons coronavirus is
ravaging our countries we have very bad
immune healthier it's we're in love with
over-the-counter drugs they make
billions and billions of dollars
slinging is dayquil and all this
horseshit that barely works right you
take it it barely makes you feel better
you really it prolongs coughs and colds
for the most part you could just get rid
of it if your immune system was stronger
it's a reality so it's great about the
CBD cryofreeze things you can put them
on there an anti-inflammatory but
they're also all-natural you know you
don't if there's no dependence you don't
develop any type of you know addiction
to it it just gets rid of pain and it
makes a lot of sense so that's oma
exhale calm enter code Tim to get 20%
off cryofreeze and site-wide so if
there's other stuff that interests you
on there too you're gonna get 20% off if
you use promo code Tim Oh max health
comm we're gonna try to get Alex Jones
on the show I want I want him to talk
about what's going on right now you know
and I don't care if you'd like it or not
I want to have Roseanne on the program
to have her talk about what's going on
right now I'd like to get Chris Hedges
on the show I want to get all of these
people on the show I don't care that you
know my biggest disappointment with some
of the people that listen to
shows when I talk to someone who
disagree with you can't handle it you
look good stupid you guys you shouldn't
do that you know I mean or or when I
talk to somebody that you find dangerous
it's like listen man
quarantines gonna end we're gonna have
to go back to work NBC pull up Drudge
NBC's already these big companies are
starting to figure out how to get people
back to work okay
fear of second wave in summer cities
began canceling fourth of July events
feds cuff feds cover up nursing home
deaths testing botched nursing home
deaths at pump that nothing to do with
coronavirus just people in nursing homes
bludgeoned you know that's what I mean
like everybody's like trying to lied
about the amount of deaths I'm like wait
what America is gonna be like hold my
beer right wait till we start burning
down nursing homes that's odd
I never was trying to collapse that
Hotel Beverly Hills orders face masks
worn in public well that's where I walk
around every day I wear them in public
you're wearing it now when you go I'm
wearing it yeah I did it today I come
down here it's come to this if you want
to go for walk at Beverly Hills into
anything else outdoors in that city
you're gonna have to cover your face
city officials have decreed that
everyone must sport some type of face
covered when they leave their homes see
this is when I would love to be able to
start a business immediately and have
the infrastructure to start making like
bedazzled masks yeah because you know
you would make a couple of MIL selling
kind of fun crazy face masks yeah that's
the type of [ __ ] I wish I could snap my
fingers and then have that
infrastructure you know Beverly Hills
mayor Lester Friedman that's the name of
the pimp and casino right is that true
yeah Sharon Stone's boyfriend and casino
last year Friedman that's [ __ ]
hilarious
yeah I guarantee you it's less or less
or daimond is it Lester diamond it's
Lester dime and I think okay oh that
sucks I thought it was last year
Friedman I don't know but the mayor of
Beverly Hills yeah Lester diamond the
mayor of Beverly Hills says you gotta
have a mask on to walk around Beverly
Hills what happens if you don't have a
mask by the way that's what I'm trying
to find out you know what are they gonna
do they probably site you you probably
get a little ticket we promise it
doesn't say law it says it's a rule it's
a rule I don't even know I don't even
know anymore folks I'm getting a little
tired of this I'm a little tired I'm a
little tired of the scientific community
not knowing anything and I think I want
them to open stop feeding the media all
this info if you don't know anything
someone cut the media is starting to
[ __ ] get out of control now they're
scaring everybody it's true conservative
show today but I'm dead serious up Trump
- he's [ __ ] up he's not doing anything
right for anybody but the media's like
the coronavirus lives in your ass you
know it's like stop I'm trying to sleep
coronavirus can come in and [ __ ] you in
your mouth at night it's like how about
know where the scientists they don't
[ __ ] know anything turn it off
turning engine it off Italy extends
locked out despite business pressure
dude Italy remember the beginning Italy
was singing to each other on their
balconies and now they are stealing food
cuz they're desperate and hungry and
this is the future of America and I'm
telling you right now I don't want
anybody to get sick and I understand why
we had to do this but we got to figure
out a way to start opening the economies
back because not we're poor vulnerable
people get get killed because that's
what's happening now but we got to
figure out a way whether it's you know
testing mitigation to be get because
this thing will spiral out of control
very quickly without even the idea we
need
the idea that that we're gonna come back
even if it's even if it's not the
reality in the near term we need the
idea that we're gonna come back which is
why they were talking several big
companies you're like listen we're gonna
have people come in try to find that NBC
companies you know big companies
thinking about how they're gonna be
bring people back to work how they're
gonna bring their workforce back here's
the thing guys until schools are in
session there is no way right there it's
still school until schools are in
session
there is never we're not gonna be back
in business because people need to watch
their kids so the reality is you need to
put the [ __ ] kids in school before
people can go back to anything that
seems like normal sitting so here's what
they're doing okay they're saying this
they're basically saying that they're
gonna try to start to bring people back
a lot of companies are gonna start to
bring people back into early May
Chrysler Tesla ball saying they begin
production again on May 4th
these are factories and they're gonna
take some you know as many precautions
and steps as they need to some things
and this is great interesting they said
for some things demand will snap back
immediately
dentists health care barbershops there's
a backlog of demand people need haircuts
they need appointments at a dentist
health care so those are things that
immediately people gonna need to do
restaurants and bars people might want
to go they're all cooped up they might
want to go out if they're open are
people gonna start buying new cars and
new homes that's gonna be a bit take a
beat on that that's gonna be a little
bit of an issue you know I mean people
are not gonna be making big purchases
immediately okay if they can help it
it's gonna be a gradual process this is
the article here all right any return to
work will be a gradual process rather
than setting a national go back to the
office -
still many companies are ready in a
hurry to get employees back to work well
they don't care they don't care people
die that's the other problem these
companies don't give a [ __ ] Goldman
Sachs is gonna build like an infrared
you know they're gonna get infrared
technology to see if you have a fever
but you can also be asymptomatic for 14
days without a fever so child care is
the big one one major limitation of any
reopening will be child care where are
you gonna put these kids now your kids
are home they're stealing your heroin
and they're stealing your bullets and
your gun they got to go back to school
you know these kids are little demons
they're on the dark web [ __ ] trying
to figure out the best route as soon as
school opens up to try to figure out the
best route through to back with dak you
got to get him out of your [ __ ] house
little tick tock monsters I can't wait
till the governor's like the retards in
the middle of the country because a lot
of them are [ __ ] start just letting
people out and just it'll be a bloodbath
or maybe not we don't know what's that
guy Tate Reeves
in Mississippi what's the Mississippi
governor's name he's my favorite Tate
Reeves yeah he's like a character can we
play some Tate Reeves
he's like a character
they're my dirt Mississippi brother was
one of the fattest states in the country
Mississippi by the way is just it's look
it you can't see this everybody I wish
we had to switch her which is
backordered I wish we could show you
this here's mine here's my big issue now
I'm gonna be very honest with everybody
when did the sign language people start
losing their minds dude the sign
language people have become so
distracting that people with ears cannot
listen because they've become so extra
have you ever seen a [ __ ] sign
language but they're like this you like
[Music]
it's like what the [ __ ] going on
what kind of theatrical sign language is
that like this is there every sign
language interpreter looks like this is
their moment like they're gonna get
picked up they're gonna get discovered
while they're doing sign language next
to the Mississippi Governor comment the
[ __ ] down some of us still have ears and
we're trying to pay attention and you're
dancing in the upper right hand corner
of the screen
and it's distracting you literally look
like you're having a full-scale seizure
on on this what is this how many deaf
people in there that we need to have
this me and Ray we're talking about this
I I you know the Deaf are really tough
the blind are lovely because they're
more vulnerable but the Deaf er is very
nasty people for the most part that's
that's the reality you know okay I you
like Marlee Matlin fine the deaf for an
issue and I've sympathy for them but I'm
saying enough with the the sign language
people that have lost their [ __ ]
minds they're preventing people from
getting the information because people
like what is wrong with that person what
is wrong I mean the guy here and we're
gonna show you this because this will be
the clip from the show but this gun is
this guy never in my life have I seen
anything like what I'm looking at right
now screenshot this and throw this on
the this great yeah you you you have to
see this because this is completely out
of control and and by the way it's not
only him it's every whether it's de
Blasio whether it's coma every sign
language interpreter is going crazy they
are signing so big it is wild and it is
incredibly distrait throws you off your
eyes travel to the sign language person
and you start you're like what is that
even sign like this Trump have one I
don't know he might he problems about
this yeah let's see what a Reeves that's
to say he looks I personally wouldn't
hold one if I was a pastor but I don't
think what was happening
Sunday based on what I've seen is in
violation of my original order I've been
clear that no American government has
the right to threaten to lock someone up
for practicing their faith that is not
legal and it is not right in Mississippi
churches are protected from over-the-top
actions like these that is spelled out
in our executive order I've said many
many times and I'm going to say is sign
language guy looks homeless I mean I've
never sign language God looks like he
has coronavirus and he looks like he's
signing honest I mean he's got this
weird black shirt the only other person
I've seen where that is the great Raycom
yeah you know it's the only other person
that was a black shirt is Ray Kampf this
guy and lounge singers that we're like a
black weird type of shirt like this it's
like a weird dude Tate Reeves looks he's
like hang tight raves I've been clear no
government can't can't put people in
jail for worshipping their faith
worshiping their God which I agree hey
Tate I agree with you I also think we
got to be a little you know keep keep
playing Tate Reeves please I'm gonna get
a job working friend and I will admit it
pains me to do so but I do not think
anyone should attend gatherings of any
type including church services with more
than 10 people there okay
this is still America we still hold our
religious liberties dear I'll be happy
to answer questions about that but I
want to make clear for all local
officials who are wondering as we enter
the second week of shelter-in-place and
Easter Sunday Mississippi is not a state
that uses government threats to shut
down churches I personally plan to
worship from home on Sunday with my
family we never missed Easter service
before and we won't miss the chance to
worship in our home
I hope all Mississippians will celebrate
responsibly and take precautions to stay
safe stay home if you can worship from
home please use common sense
be smart look out for your loved ones
I want you to know today also that we
have taken some really impressive I want
to [ __ ] on tape cake did a pretty good
job this is just sign language guys I
got Kate Reeves hit with his car years
ago and he's like I'll give you a job
he's like stay home I know many of y'all
you know you want to go out want to get
baptized Easter by the way always kind
of sucked as a holiday yeah Joey sucks
you know you get a nice honey baked ham
or my family we did it with vinegar
mustard glaze whatever you know you can
do some lamb maybe do a nice herb
crusted rack of lamb maybe a nice
Chateaubriand you don't do a casserole
on Easter you don't do pasta
Jesus Christ is coming back you [ __ ]
animal you do meat
you don't do fish to fish it's a roast
you know two vegetarians you know do
vegans you do a roast of meat you kill
an animal or you buy an animal that's
already been killed and that's what you
do that's the Easter meal you do au
gratin potatoes if you can they are the
best Easter potatoes au gratin potatoes
represent the spring chocolate should be
only for the bunny you should do like
spring pastries pastry creams glazed
fruit it's the return of lighter
desserts but still kind of heavy because
we're not quite in the summer so we're
not doing like sorbet and [ __ ] like that
you know that's if you're I mean you
know if you know can't really have an
event this year usually I try to give
advice for people that are trying to
have events that are trying to escape
the drudgery and weariness of their
horrific lives so I tell them what to
cook and what to drink but they can't do
that this year they have to just live in
the horror that they've built for
themselves you know this quarantine
really makes you think it makes you
realize that the most important thing in
the world is to have a lot of money lots
and lots and lots of money
love is meaningless and your family and
your friends in many cases are obstacles
to truly what you can do you have to
throw those people away as quickly as
possible
push them in front of trains push them
out the window of a high-rise apartment
building smother them with pillows in
your sleep they want you to fail they
don't want you to do better than they
did this means your parents and everyone
near you you have to get away from them
you should only keep friends for 24
months at that point you've gotten
everything you can from them and you
should throw them away act like you
don't know who they are push them in
front of a train out of a high-rise
apartment building smother them in their
sleep throw a hair dryer in the tub
doesn't matter whether those are
metaphorical suggestions or real ones or
is up to you to decide you need to be a
stick and move hustler keep going keep
fighting don't get stuck in a bad
situation whether it's a job whether
it's a relationship or whether it's a
family unit nothing matters get away
from these people trust me they're
trying to kill you you just don't see it
don't fall for hucksters like the Gary
V's of the world they tell you that
you're gonna start your business and
you're gonna be this brilliant
innovative person don't do that get a
simple job and steal get a simple job
and learn the way around it learn how to
steal stealing is so important steal
take take pad your pocket with the
extras find a way to circumvent the
system little crimes are very important
when it comes to survival these are
things you're all gonna need to learn
how to do okay even if it's just
stealing ketchup one day its ketchup
next day and someone's pension be smart
play the long game if I could do it all
over again I wouldn't have gone near
comedy this circus tent freak show I
would have been in good shape I would
have stayed thin and I would have done
like you know what Matt Damon did
talented mr. Ripley I would have just
stealing someone's identity murdered
them and tried to become them
that is also a great strategy for
success murder someone and become them
you don't hear that often you don't hear
that usually hear like go to grad school
that's not helping that's not helping if
you want big gains you have to take big
risks okay get comfortable with death
murder extortion blackmail violence
corruption betrayal these are all things
that you'll need to get very comfortable
out to succeed in America
imagine a priest giving this Easter
sermon to people like wouldn't be great
if a priest just giving this sermon is
like a bunch of ladies with big hats
they're all nodding themselves in a big
southern Church is like the first thing
y'all need to do is understand that you
got apply pressure to the right people
understand that secrets are power and
leverage is necessary to get what you
want know the Lisa yes praise Jesus
praise the Lord praise the Lord
what's a joke and what's not it's up to
you to decipher folks it's really not my
business I I just offer you what I can
offer you and I'm just telling you that
the Quarantine makes you think about
things how how truly blessed we are to
have this moment right before the world
descends into chaos and violence I mean
in five years the idea of something
being true or not will be funny yeah the
idea of truth will only be laughable
because we will have gone we will have
descended by that point into a
collective state of madness truly the
future of this country is a permanent
state of schizophrenia brought on by the
media an endless assault of Technology
narcissistic personalities injecting
their opinions into everything you will
fall victim and prey to the monsters
that are coming to eat whatever is left
of this decayed system you have no
choice right or wrong in terms of like
true or not true what's real news and
fake news if somebody even suggests that
you'll just start to laugh maniacally
like Joker
pretty soon we're heading there pretty
quickly there will be no value to truth
in the future there will be a collective
split of reality some people will live
in one some people will live in another
a lot of people will have one foot in in
each world I mean it's gonna splinter
there will be no more one reality we're
heading into and I'm not trying to sound
like in LA
you know Looney tune we're heading to a
place where people don't really have an
interest in realities that don't confirm
to their thoughts ideas opinions beliefs
they want to live in their own reality
some people gonna live in their own
reality and your reality is gonna come
with your own media your own figures
your own gods your own date ease your
own myths you know it's gonna come with
all of these things it's gonna be
prepackaged and sold to you and you're
no longer going to need any objectivity
because it won't exist your reality is
going to come fully fleshed out just
waiting for you to absorb it and become
it wholly totally completely there will
be no more compromise there will be no
more truth no more objectivity there
will only be the [ __ ] darkness that
you'll live in for the rest of your days
until your physical body decides to quit
another fun thing on Easter is a quiche
like if you do a ham and cheese or
quiche Lorraine you could do one with
vegetables and or something like that
because they are that is kind of a fun
appetizer enjoy the holiday